here we go it's time for another live
reading from my book reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france you may be
hearing a good bit of background noise
which is unavoidable there is
construction going on just a block and a
half from here
at what's now the milwaukee tool
building and the wisconsin center is
being torn down and built back up as
well so hopefully
uh the town comes through all right so
today we are
making our way at long last after doing
many of these readings into part three
of this book
and we're going to be looking at a
translation
of antonin districtian opie that's order
of preachers so he's a dominican
on christian philosophy and this piece
was published in a french journal called
la vie antelectumal which was
a pretty important
journal
it was more popular i would say than
academic
and it was it was pretty important in
the 1930s
quite a few pieces on christian
philosophy
were published in la viento
and so this is in uh volume 24 number
one and 1933 so now we're you know kind
of deep
into the debate
so with no further ado here is antonin
certian on christian philosophy
speaking formally and with complete
rigor about the term there has not been
there cannot be christian philosophy
the noun and the adjective are
essentially ill-fitting and can only
more or less accidentally be assembled
together although they then can with
truth whoever says the word philosophy
names a doctrine grounded in reason
proceeding only by demonstration and
knowing at least by itself only objects
of reason
whoever says the term christian
attributes to that doctrine that it is
grounded in faith that is proposing
objects of faith and reasoning and
virtue of faith
these two are contradictory mr londell
who holds for a closer connection
recognizes that the expression remains
beset by amphibologies
still along with victor elbow he would
say that his philosophy is christian and
even catholic by nature and not by
accident
the expression is admittable in which
sense we shall soon specify but
admissible under the condition that it
also be admitted is not rigorous
the entire question is therefore one of
determining more precisely the degree
and the nature of possible desirable or
obligatory intimacy between philosophy
and christianity
it seems to me that as mr zhilson has
correctly seen in order to arrive at a
judgment looking at history is not
without its usefulness
we can even advantageously go back
further in time than he does among the
ancient peoples who had little developed
intellectually philosophy was not
distinguished from religion
their differentiation was produced by
the development of reflection which
little by little substitutes itself for
instinctive spontaneities
but there is never radical separation
even in aristotle's work where the
differentiation takes place to the
maximum degree
in the case of the judeo-christian
revelation things take place in a
different way regarded from the
viewpoint of the religious finales cause
which is transcendent in that revelation
but paralleling still takes place from
the viewpoint of their form at the start
there are revolutions but instinctive
form a little rationalized technically
speaking they become little by little
more explicit up to the time of the
gospel which gives them precision and
fulfills them but there they still do
not take systematic form they are
elements
of life and to be sure of rational life
but not of science
it is through contact with intellectual
circles heirs to ancient thought and by
professional philosophers such as saint
justin saint clement of alexandria or
saint augustine adhering to christianity
that in the conciliar documents
themselves dogmas of faith take and will
take on a more rational form while a
theology and a philosophy inspired by
faith are also progressively formed the
official documents themselves are never
systematized they do not express a
philosophy even though they contain a
philosophy in a virtual state that one
can extract from them
the technical expressions used by the
documents of faith are only vehicles and
do not present between themselves
syllogistic but rather vital connections
and for that reason connections of a
deeper nature
but the thinker who adheres to doctrine
cannot remain there he tries normally to
disengage the philosophy latent in dogma
and in this he actually does
philosophy's work fitting his rational
philosophy there if he has one
and if this philosophy is capable of
philosophically examining to the extent
that it can dogma
itself in so far as dogma in one way or
another interests or conditions
philosophy's own object
the thinker thereby produces for himself
one thought and not two which would be
an inhuman and bifurcated life
also if the philosopher who adheres to
christianity means to conduct his
discipline by completely abstracting
from the object of faith to construct
thereby a philosophy complete and
sufficient in its own order
this philosophy would be false
since it would thereby remove from his
consideration not only the revelation
that is a fact
but also that which is a possibility and
a positive possibility
having an object that philosophy can
and ought to recognize
since it is admitted according to saint
thomas at least as i with many others
interpret him that the existence of a
supernatural order and the possibility
of its communication by divine
omnipotence can be demonstrated
likewise this philosophy would rule out
the study of revelations compatibilities
of the calling that is in us which again
st thomas points out the call of our
intellectual and practical aspirations a
superhuman curiosity a desire in short a
profound dynamism that orients us
towards a destiny both impossible to
attain by our own powers and impossible
to remove from our life drive even
though this does not determine its form
these are philosophical questions about
which saint thomas the philosopher was
not ignorant we have a habit of treating
them as apologetics
but if apologetics properly called as a
function of theology as father garagu
lagrange recently explained and since
this is actually true
apologetics presupposes faith
but
these questions do not presuppose faith
at all
they head out to encounter it
and these are not the only questions to
study in their generality such as i have
formulated them they impose themselves
in detail on all the forms are
theoretical and practical activity
presents they affect the problem of
knowledge the problem of being and its
first causes the problem of action in
all of its domains in short philosophy
as a whole considered under a certain
relation
that is not by consideration of what we
possess we in our conjoined environment
but relative to what we lack
that toward which we strive having to
say what objectively corresponds to this
striving in so far as it corresponds to
and evokes this striving
in this respect it seems to me that mr
blondel's work is of infinite value
and that if one may differ in opinion
with him on certain theses
for example his critique of knowledge by
concepts where in any case if we wanted
to treat both sides favorably agreement
would perhaps not be too difficult
in any case this does not affect his
general method and this works necessity
all of this is found in a dispersed
state in our author's works but not most
often
under a philosophical light here it is
some theology there are some apologetics
and this serious inconvenience ensues
that what is properly called philosophy
can believe itself in the right when
while maintaining its claim to be a
complete and comprehensive knowledge it
ignores one type of wisdom
but this is false and it would be a
great achievement to force our
philosophers by pursuing them onto their
own ground
to recognize this congenital deficiency
a positive one i would like to say by
privation and not simply by lack and
consequently
to recognize the supernatural's quasi
presence to every page of philosophy
itself if they don't recognize it they
would then have to say why
mr blondel's experiment proves that this
conquering boldness does not fail to
inspire respect and provoke useful
reflections among its opponents
we ought then to observe that the
principal obstacle to faith among uh
philosophers taken as such as the
pretension to sufficiency and to suffice
onto themselves in so far as they've not
gotten out of that pretension on their
own grounds and by their own methods
ambiguities continue christianity
affirms solutions the opponent considers
them to be not open roads and even to be
offensive for he has his own solutions
our motives of credibility
in favor of a doctrine super added to
that type of wisdom believing itself
comprehensive and complete appear
unacceptable a priori and they are soon
led to see in them only nurse maids
fables
we hear this every day
the autonomy of thought a just claim in
itself from a general point of view sets
itself up willingly as an absolute
and it seems it has the right to do so
insofar as it has not been limited
philosophically
doubtless this could be carried out
simply by pleading god's rights god's
completely gratuitous bounty but how
more effectively
by
correlatively showing man's needs and
callings can a philosopher think that
god exercises rights on his creation
without any objective justification
that he adds on to his work called
natural a surplus that under any
hypothesis will be gratuitous but would
then be only a kind of detached section
if philosophy can satisfy philosophical
man the philosopher can say
that christianity is something
superfluous that at any rate it only
represents a surplus it is permissible
to refuse or has so many philosophers
try to do to try to obtain for oneself
by means of some surpassing within the
interior of autonomy itself
it is on precisely this ground that a
fundamental and basic labor a radical
analysis what mr blondel calls a
sanitation radica seems necessary
but his is an effort we can call an
effort of christian philosophy in i have
said an always deficient sense although
it's still more fundamental if not more
profound sense than that which is
ordinarily envisaged for example the one
to which mr gilson makes recourse in his
otherwise admirable studies of history
so valuable for all of us or mr mara
tanzan is an essay on christian
philosophy where the distinction between
the essence and state of philosophy
shines a strong light but one that in my
opinion does not illuminate the whole
problem and one also in my opinion that
is wrong
in seeming to rule out other solutions
in both cases ann and mr muratins work
more explicitly because they're
doctrinally they envision only partial
objective contributions still of central
value and subjective reinforcements
they seem to declare that if philosophy
does not suffice for the concrete man it
suffices for itself as wisdom without
there being room to note a lack in its
very interior and insufficiency inviting
one to exceed it
we hear a distinction being made between
the insufficiency of philosophy that is
for man in the supernatural state that
he is in really and a philosophy of
insufficiency that would apply to man is
such envisaged in his very nature
however further on
mr maraten affirms that he sees in every
great philosophy a mystical aspiration
there is this is a great truth but from
that point on is becoming conscious of
this aspirations reasons an object not a
philosophical
labor and would this not be a philosophy
of insufficiency in relation to a
philosophy hypothetically separated from
faith
if
one constructs this philosophy
as mr blondel has tried and tries to do
one greatly surpasses the viewpoint of
partial contributions and of the
welcome a christian thinker must always
give them in this way he founds a
doctrine that is christian by
anticipation
so to speak a preface to the gospel
incomparably much more so than plato's
doctrine a doctrine that contains
christianity in an empty space within
itself
in a certain way even though it cannot
in any way determine
what would be the full form or
better expressed one that in this way
contains catholicism itself thanks to
the universality and the price character
of the researches and the demands
this philosophy does not travel side by
side with faith content with a
concordance with faith in the sense of
nowhere contradicting it and borrowing
its theses from faith it goes out to
encounter with faith in such a way as to
articulate itself with it
or better expressed
for this can still take place without
confusion with theology
in such a way
as to closely marry it in all its parts
when faith will overshadow it accepting
the paradox the scandal as mr mars mr
gabriel marcel says of the irrational by
superiority becoming then a christian
philosophy in an even more full sense in
the sense that maul brush dreamed of
without him arriving at it precisely
because he sought to attenuate the
scandal that saint augustine dreamed of
arriving at as much as his times
permitted and that as it seems to him mr
gabriel marcel drew himself dreams of
again
with mr mara 10 somewhat unexpected
approbation
that is
by a purely rational method but
receiving dogmas under the rubric of
facts just as much as experience is this
not the experience of christ community
communicated to christ brethren
we will speculate
by taking account of the entire datum
without confusion of method of
principles or of object with theology
but still reconnecting philosophy with a
total wisdom
would it be normal that a discipline
pressing its claims to the title of
wisdom
that is claiming a total systematization
of being and of life by abstraction
takes away from the one thing necessary
that it be envisaged as a possibility a
desire or a fact
clearly it is faith alone that is placed
on us and alone practically could place
us as philosophers on such a trail
consequently engaging us in all these
sorts of sublime implications
but this wrongs philosophy's autonomy
neither with respects to its methods nor
i repeat with respect to its object
a little footnote here
on this point i have furnished more
precise remarks in my communication at
the meeting of the thomas society of
11th september one will find them in the
account of that meeting and translator's
notes certian's remarks are to be found
in la la philosophy
uh uh 11 september uh 1933 right he was
also deeply involved in the discussions
in that that session all right back to
the point
back to the text and though it could not
by itself predict the approach of such
an abyss of light nor examine the
nostalgia found within itself it is
incumbent on christian philosophy to
establish a sign of this deficiency
moreover faith confirms for us to the
methods legitimacy and fruitfulness
since it teaches us that man has never
actually been in a state of pure nature
but rather that from the beginning on he
was called to a supernatural order that
he's persisted in it while a sinner and
that he has been subsequently redeemed
so that he bathes now in a bath of grace
if i may say so in the heart of the
universal church
even supposing that the supernatural
exerts no effect at all and that the
supernatural would not be in itself
discernible and isolatable
one must admit that the real man by
opposition to the animal ratzianale of
abstract concepts provides material for
a study that as philosophical as it may
be
will contain something something
completely other than that of an
aristotle who nevertheless because he
himself as well labored on the same
matter although before christ's
redemption presents here and there
some glimpses of it such as pascal's
point of view and it seems to me
we can only make it our own
mr maraten admits this point of view and
places it in full light in the domain of
morals practical science although he
seems to reject it entirely when it's a
matter of philosophy in general
not that he rejects far from that an
alliance and an intimate alliance
between philosophy and dogma and
speculative manners but it is only an
alliance in morals it is an implication
formally speaking moral philosophy could
exist only under the aspect of a part of
doctrine abstractly distinguished from
complete and comprehensive doctrine and
complete and comprehensive morality
would itself be a necessarily
theological science or at least
subordinated to theology
it seems to me that there is some
discordance here speaking in terms of
general doctrine he tells us there is a
philosophy independent of theology not
at all subordinated to it one that being
exercised in a christian regime is
called christian philosophy
this is a concise solution
but is it still when he refuses the
refuses the benefits to a domain of
philosophy as important as moral
philosophy is moral philosophy no longer
philosophy moreover how can one
dissociate so as to judge them different
from a formal point of view disciplines
as connected as moral philosophy itself
psychology even speculative the
metaphysics of the soul and metaphysics
in general
any more than in another sense from
sociology and to politics
in order to justify this exception mr
mariten argues from this point
that only religion knows the real end of
man and his real existential conditions
but if religion must provide philosophy
at the real end of man and his
existential conditions must it not
consequently and by the same
justification
provide philosophy with the first
principle that corresponds to that end
namely grace in its very essence and by
thinking upon grace's origin just as
consequently provided with the
incarnation in the trinity
one cannot ask philosophy to receive
half portions of doctrine that from its
point of view would be unformed would be
monsters if it receives the whole then
it is wholly subordinated and it is no
longer true to attribute to it the
strict autonomy we recognized as having
at the start even in a christian regime
in short it seems to me that mr moratan
and in my thought this is praise has in
an appendix considerably weakened
the thesis he presented so strongly in
his first paragraph following st thomas
and albert the great preoccupied with
conserving philosophies of autonomy
under any hypothesis
and clearly st thomas's systematization
on this point remains entirely whole
there is an autonomous philosophy and in
order to render it complete and
comprehensive and to make of it in that
sense of christian philosophy it is not
necessary to turn it into a theological
science nor into a science properly
subordinated to theology for it retains
its own methods its object and its
principles
but
when rendered foreign in every manner to
the objects of faith it becomes a
philosophy
for outsiders who are content deprived
of lights emanated from faith we abandon
that philosophy to them we recognize its
rights even when having decided to
demand these rights for ourselves
but for ourselves we are not at all
content with this i say as
philosophers we set this philosophy to
work only after making deep
methodological and objective corrections
to it this is not a philosophy of the
christian philosopher and the reason for
that is is a the philosophy of a pure
abstract and not even completely
explored essence
setting aside this last point on which
i've recently explained myself
one can say that a philosophy whether
theoretical or practical that claims to
be autonomous in the sense that it
affirms itself to have no organic
connection with faith to travel in its
own direction leaving faith to travel on
its own but still relying on its truth
to not contradict the truth of faith
accepting its control not refusing
itself some partial contributions if
they seem to belong by right to its own
domain in short
adopting descartes position with minor
corrections
that philosophy completely right as it
is in its moral attitude with respect to
the true is all the same only a
philosophy
of the concept of man of the concept of
nature or the concept of society
not a philosophy of man of nature or of
society in the concrete
opposition a christian philosophy
spontaneously in conformity with the
lights and demands of revelation as mr
blondel says can be called must be
called as it seems to me the philosophy
of the real and by that fact the real
philosophy if our spirit of truth does
not give way on this point to the
temptations of secularization and holds
itself back from any human prestige
i conclude
from this that mr mariten's formula
qualifying christian philosophy is
philosophy simplicity
living historically in a christian
regime and enjoying thereby the
objective and subjective reinforcement
supplied by faith is a perfectly and
luminously comprehensive formula but
only under this condition
first that it does not amputate from
philosophy simply tear the beginnings
with which the naturally christian soul
provided
second of
permitting it on the theoretical just as
much as on practical grounds and under
the same rubric of philosophy simplicity
the use by its own means according to
its own methods and to the advantage of
its own object left to itself of new
facts in the doctrinal order even if
they be imported from heaven
without this under christian
philosophy's usurped name we will have
nothing more than the philosophy of an
abstract essence
not
a abstract uh here we go uh nothing more
than the philosophy of an abstract
essence conceivable but
christianly non-existent
and this very abstract essence itself
not having been considered as a
spiritual nature in its congenital
insufficiencies and its demanding
dynamism would have been incompletely
analyzed
practically falsified to the common
detriment of philosophy of faith and of
their authentic
relationships so that is antonin
sirtiage one of his many contributions
to the debate the one that i translated
called on christian philosophy taken
from la vie on to lexuel volume
24
uh
issue number
number one from 1933 and what we see
there
i'll address questions and comments when
when you write them
what you see there is is certions who is
a very important french thomas thinker
saying that you know jilsa and martha
they're right about their position on
christian philosophy but they don't go
far enough
and what's needed is actually maurice
blondell's uh insights as well that he's
articulated which jill so and martin are
wrongly rejecting about the need to
realize that philosophy is never really
sufficient to itself and it has these
gaps or holes or fissures within itself
that need to be
examined and explored on a philosophical
basis and then going even further
and saying by the way gabriel marcel is
also bringing something to the table and
we need to take into account
his position as well so certian's um
argument here certian's claims here are
basically that the other key people in
the debate have brought forth key
insights about
what philosophy would actually need to
look like in order to be genuine
philosophy in order to not truncate
itself and that would mean engaging
however difficult this is with
christianity not in a way that's kind of
just cut and paste or
you know trying to find some sort of
concordance or subordinating philosophy
to theology
but rather in a way that stays true to
the genuine aims of philosophy which if
they were in the present here they would
say many people doing philosophy today
have actually lost and misunderstood
um so that's that's sir tianja's
contribution i by the way i'm a big fan
of siertiange a lot of his stuff isn't
translated unfortunately but he's got
some really
amazing writings on saint thomas he does
actually have a book that i can highly
recommend to you which is a you know
more down-to-earth thing called the
intellectual life which is kind of a
handbook for
how to live a life of the mind um
translated by uh james shaw a jesuit
all right mark says there was a point
made about christian philosophy as a
philosophy of the real as opposed to
descartes philosophy as being too
abstract perhaps i misunderstood but
could you say more on that yeah so um
it's not just descartes he's using
descartes as an example of that
philosophy
is always
metaphilosophical meaning that
philosophy doesn't just do what it's
doing it's always like making at least
some implicit claims about what counts
as
philosophy
what what actually
can work for it and
how philosophy ought to be understood
and conducted
so
many of the
ways to understand philosophy end up
sort of drawing limits you think about
kant as a good example as well right
kant is very clear about what he thinks
to be the limits of philosophy turns out
that kant is wrong about that hume is
another another good example descartes a
lot of early moderns are doing this the
analytics by saying oh philosophy can
only basically be you know looking at
language and we're not going to read all
this other stuff from the past all this
crazy crap um
hegel himself is is limited in this way
it becomes less philosophy is a living
thing
and it becomes or as an activity that we
actually engage in and we see how far we
can go with it
and it becomes a
representation if we want to use hegel's
terms a forced
right of philosophy it's no longer
really conceptual
and it's no longer really connected to
the totality of human existence so this
is this is a very you know big picture
conception of philosophy that the people
you know talking with each other in in
this debate tend to share
um although some of them i would say
mara 10 is a little bit limited in this
respect um
so it imposes a great challenge you know
how do we do
justice to the real which includes
you know
not just
say our psychology or our bodies you
know big themes of 20th century
continental philosophy or language and
all that how do we take into account
the fact that
religion was
and still is for many people and many
great intellectuals
an important factor in their life can we
just like strip it off and say yeah as
soon as philosophy starts talking about
religion it's no longer philosophy it's
now become apologetics
if we do that we become unphilosophical
we become
sort of
caught within the grips of an
abstraction that we don't realize
ourselves
this doesn't uh by the way mean that
there couldn't be other things that a
christian philosopher might be leaving
out right
so you know a marxist could respond and
say hey you're not paying enough
attention to the economic structures of
things and maybe that's a good response
you know
maybe there's a lot of things that we
need to be more
uh clear about and try to bring into
philosophy even though it's difficult to
do
all right um
some comments here about good content on
the channel
uh great political theory video with
stoicism published back in 2020 i i'm
not sure which one that would be because
i've published like over 200 videos on
stoicism um
so uh yeah um
i'm glad people get something out of
the channel and uh
that's that's about
all i can really say about that um
so
while we're uh waiting to see if anybody
else has things that they they want to
say i'll mention that uh something this
is not connected to the book but
something really cool
took place last night i did my first
face-to-face
presentation since covid began
since we went into lockdown of course
masked up and you know socially
distanced and stuff like that and the
philosophers in the midst of history uh
session and we did talk about god a good
good bit because it was focused on um
it was focused on plutarch who is a
middle platoonist and the plaintiffs
very interested in the nature of god
and we ranged over a lot of stuff we
talked a little bit about um
christianity although plutarch you know
wasn't conversant with it um there were
some early christian
authors at the time that he was around
all right mark says um
oh
uh more general question but i've been
using these sessions to think about my
own relationship with christ do you have
any suggestions about where someone
could go with that sorry if that's vague
yeah i mean
there's all sorts of places um i mean i
i think that
reading the gospels and reading them
without trying to like impose anything
on them and just seeing
you know what they actually say about
this guy and what the early early
christian authors who wanted to discuss
him
what they were impressed by
that is
something that you want to go back to
all the time and then you know remember
too that
this jesus guy
was
often bringing up the the
hebrew scriptures right um he quotes
from isaiah and he brings up the psalms
and stuff like that so knowing something
about that can be helpful
and then you know i think seeing what
other people have to say about him you
know reading some of the early christian
you know so christian philosophers right
justin martyr is somebody who antonin
sertian mentioned clement of alexandria
reading what these early christians have
to say actually i'll bring something up
which is not
all that related but it's something from
my medieval philosophy class we had our
first online class session
and you know i'm having them read uh
prudentius's psychomachia and then this
coming week we're beginning three weeks
on augustine's confessions and then
we're reading some bits of city of god
and then we're reading boethius and then
we're reading we're spending a week on
uh gregory the greats moralia and job
the stuff about the seven deadly sins
and alchemins on virtues and vices and
then we're doing three weeks on uh saint
anselm of canterbury a big you know big
favorite of mine
and then we're doing um saint bernards
on the love of god and we're finishing
up by the letters between abelard and
eloise so we're really only going
through you know
early medieval period into the middle
medieval period before the high
um middle ages we're not talking about
um
we're not talking about uh
uh dominicans or franciscans or any of
that sort of stuff and why are we doing
that well because you know it's triage
you can if you bring other stuff in you
can't concentrate on as much
the point that i made to my students is
whatever experiences you've had with
christianity in your life in the present
those those are all real
and the people met in the books that
you've read
you know that's that's real stuff
don't import any of that
as you're reading these early media
authors their christianity
is not the same thing that you
experienced it's it's connected with
some of the same ideas some of the same
texts some of the same problems
but they were thinking about these
things in very very different ways and
even if you're a catholic and you know
augustine is a catholic your catholicism
is not exactly the same thing no matter
even if you had people who taught about
augustine it's not the same thing as
what augustine himself was was going
through so you want to like just open
your eyes and open your ears and see
what's actually there
on the page before you know saying oh i
don't like christianity or oh
christianity's so wonderful we've got to
see what these thinkers are actually
saying and thinking and i think that
that's a useful way of approaching these
early you know spinoza says church
fathers need more attention yeah i mean
justin martyr irenaeus
clements
you know john cassie and there's all
sorts of people that are that are worth
like reading see what the hell do they
make of this this you know religion that
they're
in some cases converted to
or living out a life within and i think
that that can be quite helpful um john
cassian
actually makes a really interesting
point about christ
um
he's talking to monks people who are
like
spiritually uh ascetic they they've
focused their life on on you know
removing themselves from society
and trying to pray and you know follow
the christian path
and john cassian says
no single person can have all the
virtues as a matter of fact you're lucky
if you even possess one of them
you know who does
christ
and in your participation in that
through the community
you might actually be able to do your
little share so you've got you know a
virtue and this person has a virtue and
this person has a virtue and we put them
together in community
and we get virtues um
you might say that's pessimistic cassian
would say that's realistic
and he's drawing on the you know
egyptian fathers
um
spinoza thank you for sharing the book i
was wondering if you have any thoughts
on universal reconciliation views
i've heard some scholarship recently
which argues it being the earliest view
if you mean
universalism uh which might nowadays be
called universal reconciliation by some
people i haven't heard it called that
universalism is the idea that you know
god is just gonna
give everybody a pass on whatever sins
they've done and maybe they have to go
down to hell for a little while but they
can be prayed out of hell
um
i don't think that that is the idea of
the early
uh
christians for the most part i think
it's pretty clear that that's not the
viewpoint and i think that people who
are claiming that it is they probably
have to be reading and interpreting very
very selectively and you know with with
doctrines like that you always get to
ask
what's what's a person's motive for
bringing that forward is it that they
think christianity is just too mean
because some people wind up in hell
i mean you could you could like
attenuate it and say well maybe the
babies don't go there it's only jackass
humans who behave like jerks after
they've you know reached an age of
reason or something like that but that
would still not be universalism you got
to ask what's the motive for
universalism why are people so big on
that when they are you know
i mean maybe it's a counter to a too
great emphasis on like fear of hell or
threatening people with hell there's a
lot of christians who are you know
basically just you know [ __ ] who use
christianity as a uh particular
vocabulary for being being that way
right um you know you read you read the
puritan literature right and there's
some on that end and then there's some
who are kind of cool you know and
there's a lot in between
um
so you know it's it's an interesting
topic i i just don't
to me that's kind of a non-starter to
claim that um early christians were were
um viewing things that way i mean think
about the the you know the various
hard sayings in the gospels right you
know peop some of these people are going
to be you know thrown in the outer
darkness where there's wailing and
gnashing of teeth some are going to be
burned up
spinoza says i personally think it's a
view that paul held um
yeah i don't i don't see that in paul at
all
um as a matter of fact i see lots of
things in paul that would militate
against that that you would have to
completely ignore in order to to buy
into it and you know so thomas talbott
probably not going to spend any time
reading him
because i've got too much other reading
to do i just don't consider it a
i mean there's people who have that
point of view but i think you got to
really really torture the texts
to get that point of view
max what do you think these philosophers
in france in the 1930s would say to
dawkins uh get thee behind me maybe
you're not a real philosopher
um you know why why do you make all
these vast dogmatic assumptions about
the nature of science and the nature of
faith i think they would consider him
just to be a crude secularist and not
quite up to par with the secularists or
the the uh rationalists of the time like
emil brellier who was early involved in
the debate or um
leon brunchfig who is involved in the
debate um so
i i don't think they would make much of
dawkins as a matter of fact
i think that you know here's here's an
interesting figure to bring up is a
counter position alvin plantinga right
he has a piece called advice to
christian philosophers that he writes um
in in the last you know century
and he's important in these evangelical
circles he he was at notre dame uh
teaching as well
and um plantinga ends up because he
doesn't know anything about this debate
because he he doesn't read outside of
you know
analytic philosophy much and then some
augustine and some dutch authors who had
their own christian philosophy debate
like deweyard
he doesn't know the literature and he
winds up crudely reinventing wheels i
think these guys would like look at his
advice to christian philosophers and say
wow that's a good start my man
now
catch up
i mean one of the reasons why i did the
work of translating this and then
getting it published by catholic
university of america press
is that there has never been a time when
the notion of christian philosophy
was so well debated and proposed and
investigated as during those 1930s
debates
there have been some
advances beyond that i would say
um
you know uh there you know for example
jean-luc mario actually knows about
these debates because he wrote about him
um i would say that he makes a couple
useful points i can't remember offhand
exactly what they are dietrich von
hildenbrand who knew about these debates
advances some good things about the
emotions adrian pepperzak
down at loyola
great levinos and hegel scholar also
very conversant with these debates
make some real contributions in the late
90s to what christian philosophy would
actually
look like and entail
but
they're not involved in in like a
debate across journals and books and
meetings and stuff like that like like
these guys are
um
so
yeah it's kind of interesting to think
about
all the pretty sweeping assumptions that
underlie models of philosophy that
people have
in the present day you know
i would say a lot of analytic and a lot
of continental philosophy
um
doesn't have much opening to that
max do these debates talk about islamic
philosophy in a way no because they're
not interested in islamic philosophy
they're interested in christian
philosophy
islamic philosophy is not particularly
well known in the 1930s a lot of things
are not translated
um
you got to be a little i mean when jill
some begins the uh
spirit of medieval philosophy and you
read the first page and he talks about
muslim men right you're like oh
you know your eyes kind of roll and you
feel kind of cringy
that was kind of the thing at the time i
mean we've really i would say advanced
in our appreciation and understanding of
the
pretty vast field of islamic philosophy
that's available and actually one of my
colleagues
i think is is uh
not you know the only person involved in
this but very important um richard
taylor is the aquinas in the arabs
project
based at marquette university just 12
blocks from here
you know has graduate students studying
arabic so they can actually read these
texts but
that really wasn't something that was
happening
back then as a matter of fact the reason
why there's a christian philosophy
debate is because the for you know for
the most part the french
milieu is very very secularist and the
french government the third republic is
very hostile to
uh
christianity and you know catholicism
and reformed uh christians in in
particular who are who are the
christians in in the francophone uh
world so yeah not a lot of not a lot of
contact with uh islamic philosophy um
any other questions or comments or
issues people want to
hit on
these are some pretty good ones
sometimes we
you know we don't get quite so much
max okay are you as you're doing work on
hegel do you find any overlap between
hegel and the christian philosophy
debates
um
yes and no so emil brahier brings up
hagel as one of the potential candidates
for christian philosophy in his very
first
piece in the review of metaphysical
morale is there a christian philosophy
which is the first piece translated here
in the book
and i think he's basically right in
saying that foyer bach you know more or
less
represents
what hegelian you know views on
christianity and religion are
um
he doesn't get discussed much by
anybody else
um
i i don't think that they view
him as a real contender
and you know it's good to remember that
um the phenomenology was not what what
french um
people interested in hegel were reading
until kojev and hippolyte
are talking about and translating the
phenomenology right
um
mark sharing this question again out of
curiosity any non-christian thinkers
that you thought actually gave you a
good insight into christianity
lev shestoff who's jewish
um
yeah
i would say you know he's he's he's an
interesting guy well worth reading for
his his own sake but also for what he
has to say about existentialist figures
he gets involved in the christian
philosophy debates by the way
he starts writing towards the end of the
debates
the
serialized articles that will become
athens and jerusalem which is probably
his best known work here
in the united states it's been
translated for a long time
those are in the reviewed metaphysic a
morale and i want to say the first one
let me check the bibliography
the first one i want to say comes out in
maybe 34 but it might be actually 1935
so he kind of misses his opportunity
to get
um
to get involved no it is 1935. uh it's
originally titled aten's jerusalem
concupiscentia irresistabilis right and
he'll publish
a number of follow-ups actually around
that same time
braunschweig publishes
religion philosophy which is going to
become a
book later on
on his part so
yeah
um
johan says it's great to have you doing
a live stream love your videos was
introduced to your content by my
professor and became a lifetime
subscriber oh that's very nice for you
to say yeah
i'm i'm glad to have people here um
especially for this because this is kind
of uh you know this is not my my
topics that that i think a lot of people
get into like you know the half hour
hegel series or the stoicism stuff or
the aristotle stuff or you know amas or
stuff like that so it's nice to see at
least you know some people wanting to
like uh hear about this book and the
thinkers and texts that are that are
involved in it um
going back to mark's question i'm
actually i'll tell you a story that i
heard from paul griffiths
who is a big augustine scholar but who
is involved in a lot of um
intra-religious discussions because he
started out he was actually he's from
from from
england
and then he
studied at uw-madison
and
uh specialized in in buddhism scholastic
buddhism and he was a buddhist for a
long time and then he converted to
christianity
and so you know when they would have
like let's get some buddhists and hindus
and christians together and talk about
stuff
in these interfaith dialogues he was one
of the guys who got tapped
now he was
at a conference and the and the dalai
lama was there as well
and
you know he he was they were in a church
and the dalai lama was walking across
the church
and what it what a catholic would do in
a catholic church because there's the
tabernacle and there's you know
the belief that that's the real presence
and all that is they would bow or
genuflect or something like that as
they're walking across right what
griffiths actually does griffis is is
catholic um
he he uh bows whenever he goes into any
church that has a tabernacle whether
it's you know anglican or
if there's an altar you know he he bows
before it as a symbol
what he said the dalai lama did which
was really cool the dalai lama gets to
the halfway point
and then he's kind of old and he turns
and he waves
he doesn't doesn't kneel doesn't vow
doesn't do anything like that
but
he's he's doing some sort of recognition
like sort of a cross-religious
recognition
and he waves and then he just moves on
so you know griffiths is like a young
scholar at the time and this is the
dalai lama right so it's kind of a big
deal
but he goes up to him anyways he said
what was that what were you doing there
and the dalai lama said i was just
saying hi to jesus
which is kind of a kind of a cool idea
and kind of a cool cool story uh sort of
a recognition of of another spiritual
being
by
the representative of you know a major
world religion so
that that was kind of a cool thing um
now does that actually answer mark's
question
i don't know you know
um
i don't know that that that helps out
but it it is it is kind of a
it's something that that sort of like a
parable makes you think about things you
know
all right i got about another
nine minutes before i gotta get back to
work
for the day any other
questions comments people want me to
answer grapple with or
give you
non-answers to
you know in the meantime i i will say
something about um understanding christ
chesterton gk chesterton has this great
book the everlasting man and what i one
of the things i really like about that
book is he talks about
people who want to
contrast the jesus of the gospels with
the jesus of the church right and
they're like the jesus of the church
he's a mean guy you know they they took
this wonderful stories about him and
they turned him into a task master a
judge and all that
the jesus of the gospels he's all
forgiving and super nice and stuff like
that and then chesterton says it's clear
that you know people who endorse that
point of view have never actually read
the gospels because the situation is
actually completely reversed now he's
being a little hyperbolic there the
church often tends to like water the
message down because if you actually
read the gospels that [ __ ] is tough to
live up to right and if you don't live
up to it
you're on the wrong side of god right
there's all these hard sayings there's
the sermon on the mount there's all
these places where christ is just
uncompromising right
and
this is a great insight by chesterton
that he develops i think it's in like
chapter one or chapter two of the work
um i think that's kind of a you know an
interesting
way to make it out
a lot rudolph steiner and his philosophy
of christianity are taken on that i
actually dated an anthropocephist for
for you know about three years so i got
plenty of anthropos
uh it sort of like shoved down my throat
and i did some translating work for them
and i've been to the gertie on them
i don't buy it you know i think there's
some cool ideas in there but i don't buy
the steiner thing um so
you know i i don't
pay much attention to them anymore it's
been a long time since i've looked at it
uh spinoza my partner wants to know if
you personally consider yourself a
christian yeah i'm a christian i'm not a
good one
so you know and i'm not i'm not a a
model to follow i'm somebody who
wrestles with god like um
quite a few religious thinkers
have had to do i personally find
the religious thinkers most interesting
for whom belief in god or a conversion
does not mean that things become simpler
it means their whole life and the
universe becomes way more complicated
um those you know like a kicker guard or
a blonde l or or a gabriel marcel
those are the the people that i like to
be in dialogue with
um
i you know i was raised uh
you know in a religious family where
nobody really knew much of anything but
we went to church and did what we're
supposed to do and then i rebelled and
left
and came back much later on and it was
largely through you know reading um
great christian thinkers like uh
saint anselm you know
and uh
but you know there's a lot of different
ways to live out the the christian life
um
so yeah
um
let's see here
oh here's an interesting question
uh from
s bros klib what's your take on bart
airman
bart airman is somebody whose work i
used to teach when i was teaching at
indiana state prison and i had a class
called jesus in the gospel traditions
where we would look at the canonical
gospels and we would also look at
non-canonical gospels
and airmen at the start was a very good
careful scholar
um
his work af
i quit reading him frankly after the
gospel of judas because that was just
such utter crap drivel you know partisan
[ __ ] i was like wow this is a big
blind spot on this guy's part and if you
look at his biography it comes from a
christian you know very in a severe
conservative christian background
swings over to the other extreme does
some really great work then he winds up
you know like buying into basically you
know crazy cultish stuff um so
you know
um i i uh
i don't take him seriously i haven't
taken him seriously
when did the gospel of judas come out
[Music]
i was still living in indiana at the
time so
you know
late
2000s the oughts decade
but i'd say his earliest stuff was still
really good you know he's got those lost
christianity volumes there's no reason
to throw those out those are those are
good scholarship
um and i if i was teaching a similar
class i might still use his translations
so you know
this is the way we ought to be with a
lot of people we have a qualified point
of view in this respect good in this
respect not so good you know
um
all right
we've got about three minutes left
before i gotta go
um any other questions
comments well by the way we'll do
another one of these next week and that
will be
a guy who i i really like uh bruno de
solage
the problem of christian philosophy and
that one is actually a public address
that he's giving
which is then
uh
published i want to say in veontolexual
as well
yeah la vie en select well uh
volume 25 number three so a little bit
after um sartianj's piece
um
let's see
uh
us pro sklib i just wanted to say i
loved your classes on hagel's
phenomenology of spirit um yeah i'm
still continuing oh marcus what's it
mark is throwing me a softball here
what's happening this weekend political
theory and practice oh i i haven't yet
specified what the topic is uh i'll be
doing one of these political theory and
practice discussions
you know what i've been thinking about
lately the unraveling of societal and
political norms
and because it's it's particularly
problematic here in in the united states
and in our
state of wisconsin and um
i think that's kind of an interesting
topic so i'm actually going to be
bringing in
um some discussions from uh
hobbs and from de tocqueville but also
from jill de luz of all people
um so i'm i'm uh going to talk about
about the dangers that that come with
that
um and you know is there anything we can
do i kind of think there isn't a lot we
can do unfortunately
so
yeah that should that should be a a good
one um
any other uh
questions comments
uh you know
so for for wada
you can always find when anything is
happening with me by going to the reason
i owe events calendar it's got you know
all the events in uh
the calendar it's at
the political theory and practice the
discussion is at 12 noon central time so
whatever time zone you're in you want to
convert it you know
but you can always find these things
publicized on on my uh
business website reason i o
um
yeah it should be it should be a good
good talk um we'll see what what comes
of it my
i can't say that my um ideas are
completely coherent yet
um
yeah mark just gave the the website
there so you click on you know events
calendar
in one of the tabs and that will show
you when everything is
at least everything i've got scheduled
so far
[Laughter]
it takes a while sometimes to get things
set up but
so um all right it's it's one o'clock
here
i gotta get to some work
uh before i meet with a client a little
bit later today and then do a recording
session if you don't know davout gosli
uh he and i are our good friends and um
we do these little talks together um so
we're gonna be talking about humility
maybe we'll try to outdo each other in
humility in the talk or something like
that we're gonna do that tonight and
then you'll find that in his channel
he's got a great youtube channel with a
lot of stuff
um
all right spinoza thanks for the time
and answers a bit disappointed you don't
take universalism seriously but but i
believe you will be saved by yourself i
don't know that i'll be saved you know
that's the thing you know it all depends
on like
figuring your your stuff out and on
divine grace and i'm okay with that um i
don't i don't need to believe that i'll
be saved in order to like make it
through life it's enough to like hope
that
maybe through divine mercy uh uh you
know a screw-up like me because i've
screwed up a lot
but i'm still unrepentant about some of
it
will will somehow get get through you
know make it through the gate
maybe st peter won't be looking that
close at all sneak in like the tailor
does and the
brothers grimms story if anyone
remembers that one all right well thanks
for everybody
all the comments questions thanks for
your attention and i'm gonna end this
here and i'll see you uh next uh
next thursday for another one of these
and then uh those who want to go
to the political theory that'll be this
this
saturday or just coming up in two days
so i'll see some of you there as well